what are you smelling Blake wine what do
you mean
[Applause]
oh it smells delicious
this conversation deserves what
I'll drink on my show I love her
sauvignon blanc oh you do I do I like a
Pinot Noir
wait at pouring wine you do gen pores
this and that's right we both love Wine
and Food probably too much uh is there
too much I don't know it's not like I
would do it while I was being
interviewed
I love those like sommelier explanations
when they with a hint of they're like
tennis balls the tennis balls charades
spicy exciting and a little arrogant
that's what I like
oh and I'm like oh it's like ooh and
then like mine are all emotions I
usually describe wine actually like
music so okay it kind of makes sense
right it was like Amy Linux and then
ended Nina Simone yeah okay nice what
does it mean when the wine has the lice
Lakes yeah
it's funny I remember when I was in
Paris and someone asked me
don't just drink it I want you to kind
of chew the wine slightly and expose it
to all of your taste buds yeah not
usually at a dinner party but now we're
gonna do it somebody call my wife tell
her I'm coming home
[Applause]
I'm kind of proud of the fact that I can
open a bottle of wine and tell you about
the specials and distract you from the
fact that I'm not doing a great job
opening the line
[Applause]
interesting about bread is it really
fills you up it does yeah and if you're
at a party and you're holding the glass
by the bowl you're basically going to
warm your glass pretty quickly you're
not getting any if you hold your glass
but like this at a party because people
will know you're not getting any
have you heard of orange wine
right
fantastic
it's great
I'm a mother of 80 grandmother of nine
did you say mother of eight yes Mother
of eight I should have brought you one
I love this glass
it's like a bat yeah now I look like
that girl at the party
finally eating shrimp
the tomatoes
it's my favorite cheese and my favorite
wine it's my birthday head to our
Instagram stories my whole body is warm
let's just move on to the red and let's
see what happens
grab your glasses ladies do you have to
oh you have some as well ready all right
cheers oh yes the shoes Cheers Cheers
Cheers Cheers amen
[Applause]
laughs
[Music]
[Applause]